[تصفيق]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرض نرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات
وفي العناوين
ذوي اطلاق نار وتحريق للطيران الحربي في
الخرطوم والجيش يعلق مشاركته في مفاوضات
جده
م لاوكرانيا
الادعاء الالماني يتهم سبعه اشخاص بجمع
اموال لصالح داعش وارسالها للتنظيم في
سوريا
محاولات تقودها طهران باتجاه القاهره
لاستعاده العلاقات بين البلدين وصمت مصري
رسمي
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا نبدا باخبار العاجله
التي وردت علينا الى شاشه العربيه قبل
قليل حيث اتهم الجيش السريع اتهم الدعم
السريع الجيش السوداني بتعمد تعطي الهدنه
باستمرار القصف الجوي هذا واكد الدعم
السريع مشاهدينا التزامه بمفاوضات جده بعد
تعليق الجيش السوداني مشاركته فيها حيث
علق الجيش السوداني مشاركته في هذه
المفاوضات التي تجرى برعايه سعوديه
وامريكيه لوقف اطلاق النار وتسهيل وصول
المساعدات الاسريه وذكرت مراسله العربيه
ان الجيش السوداني ابلغ الوساطه في جده ان
ابلغهم بان قوات الدعم السريع لم تلتزم
ببنود الهدنه وانه لا معنى للاستمرار في
تبليدها في ظل الخرق التي ترتكبها قوات
الدعم السريع واكدت ايضا مؤسسه العربيه ان
الجيش السوداني علق مشاركته في مفاوضات
جده ولم ينسحب منها
[موسيقى]
ميدانيا ارتفعت وتيره الاشتباكات بين
طرفين نزاع في السودان ونشر الجيش
السوداني مقطعا مصورا لقواته من مدينه
الاوبيض في ولايه شمال كردفان واكد انه
تصدى لهجوم من قوه الدعم السريع على
المدينه وكبدها ايضا خسائر فادحه هذا
وافاد مراد العربيه باغلاق كبر الفتيحاب
من جهه ام درمان بالخرطوم واضاف ان
الطيران الحربي عاود التحليق في سماء ام
درمان بالتزامن مع سماع دوي اطلاق نار
متقطع في منطقه المهندسين هاتفيا مشاهدينا
من جده معنا مديره مكتب العربيه في
السودان يعقوب اهلا بك لينا وهل توفرت لك
معلومات حول هذه الخطوه التي اتخذها الجيش
السوداني بتعليق مشاركته في مفاوضات جده
مرحبا بك احمد نعم كما ذكرنا قبل قليل
ربما الجيش السوداني بعد الاشتباكات التي
وقعت امس ومحاوله الدعم السريعه لحد قوله
الاعتداء على مواقع للجيش فضلا عن اطلاق
النار من قبل الدعم السريع وكذلك عدم
الخروج من المستشفيات والمرافق العامه
ومنازل المواطنين راى ان هذه الغنه لن
يكون لها معنى خاصه انها الهدنه الثالثه
كانت هناك هدنه بين الطرفين في الحادي عشر
من مايو ثم هدنه اخرى في العشرين من مايو
وهذه هي الهدنه الثالثه
اعتبر الجيش انه في بعد توقيع كل هدنه لا
يلتزم الدعم السريع بما ورد في برود
الاتفاق وحتى ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه
او السماح لها بالدخول كانت على نطاق
محدود جدا للغايه وفي بعض الاماكن التي لا
تقع تحت نطاق سيطرته على الجانب الاخر
الدعم السريع يرى ان الجيش السوداني ظل
كذلك مستمرا في غرق الغد عبر القصف الجوي
وكذلك عبر استهداف مواقع للدعم السريع وما
اسمائها ايضا عرقله اصول المساعدات
الانسانيه اذا هناك اتهامات بين الاثنين
ولكن من الواضح واللافت ان الجيش السوداني
كان قد حدد قبل التوقيع على هذه الهدنه
نقاط معينه منها الخروج من المستشفيات
ومنازل المواطنين
والمرافق العامه هذا الامر بحسب الجيش لم
يتم حتى الان وكان هذا شرطا للتوقيع ولكن
الوساطه ضعت الطرفين الى التوقيع على
الهدنه ومناقشه هذه الملاحظات والخروقات
في خلال الخمسه ايام بعدها يومين من
التوقيع راى الجيش السوداني ان الاستمرار
فيه هدنه مع الدعم السريع لن يكون ذو قيمه
المفاوضات هل يعني بالضروره
مغادره وفد الجيش السوداني لجده الى
الخرطوم لحين معالجه هذه النقاط التي
اثرها الجيش
لا يعني انسحاب بحسب المصادر التي تحدثنا
اليها تعليق المشاركه يعني عن انهم توقفوا
عن الاجتماعات عن الالتزام بما ورد في
الهدنه
وابلغوا الوساطه بذلك وكما قلنا احمد كان
هناك اليوم اجتماع يفترض ان يعقد بين
الجيش وبين الوساطه لان المباحثات
والمفاوضات بينهما غير مباشره برعايه
الوساطه السعوديه الامريكيه
فلم يعقد هذا الاجتماع مع الوساطه باعتبار
ان هناك تعليق لهذه الهدنه وللانتزام
ببنودها الوفد السوداني ما زال باقي حتى
اللحظه في جده لا انباء عن انسحاب ولكن
يبدو انها ايضا مساحه يمكن ان تفعله
الوساطه مع الطرف الثاني
ما الذي يمكن ان يتوصل اليه
الطرفين الوساطه والدعم السريع لمحاوله
الجيش اجبار الط رف الاخر الالتزام ببعض
الب
روده لكن طبعا الدعم السريع يعني رد على
هذا البيان ببيان اخر واكد انه متمسك
وملتزم بالهدناء التي تم توقيعها في جده
وبانه ملتزم بما ورد في بنود الاتفاق طيب
لنعلم ان الوقت ما زال مبكرا لك
اي ردود فعل المياه الوساطه حتى اللحظه او
تعليقات على
قليلا نعم نعم لان كنت سالتك عن ردود فعل
اذا كانت رصدت من الوساطه على هذه الخطوه
السوداني وما صدر ايضا من تصريحات او
تعليقات الدعم السريع
احمد المعروف ان الوساطه لا تتحدث وكذلك
الوفدين الوفد السوداني الموجود في جده
وكذلك وقت الدعم السريع لم يصدر من
الثلاثه اي تصريحات خلال انعقاد فتره
المباحثات التي استمرت في خلال شهر مايو
من بدايه مايو هذه الوفود متواجده
التصريحات تكون رسميه من جانب الوساطه بعد
توقيع الهدنه الثانيه كان هناك
توقيع مصور كانت هناك يعني تصريحات
للوساطه السعوديه
لتلقيح هذا الاتفاق واملهم ان يذهب هذا
الاتفاق الى الامام ان يسهل ويمكن
السودانيين من ممارسه حياتهم بصوره افضل
الى ان تخف وتيره هذا هذه الحرب لكن طبعا
لا هناك تصريحات وهو التزام لكلاء الاطراف
في الابتعاد عن وسائل الاعلام لفتره
انعقاد هذه المحادثات لذلك لم تصدر بعد اي
ردود افعال من الوساطه السعوديه الامريكيه
المتواجده حاليا في جده شكرا لك لينا
وسنلقيعين معك على اي تطورات جديده في جده
في هذا الملف من جد كنت معنا مديره مكتب
العربيه في السودان لينا يعقوب
في خضم حرب المسيره بين موسكو اشارت نائب
بل اشار نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي
حيث نشر
قال فيها ان بريطانيا ومن خلال دعمها
الاوكرانيا بالسلاح والمعدات العسكريه
فتحت باب المواجهه بينها وبين موسكو ما
يعني ان كل مسؤول بريطاني عسكري او مدني
يمكن اعتباره هدفا عسكريا
هذا هو اعلن حاكم مقاطعه بالجورود الروسيه
تعرض منطقه شيبكيين الى قصف اوكراني مكثفه
اربعه اشخاص
الاوكرانيه ادى كذلك الى الحاق اضرار
ببنايات سكنيه ومدرسه
ومنشاتين صناعيتين وذلك بعدما اكد في وقت
سابق ان المدفعيه الاوكرانيه لا تبعد سوى
نحو 7 كيلو مترات فقط الى الشمال من
الحدود مع اوكرانيا
من جهه اخرى مشاهدينا اعلنت السلطات
المواله لروسيا في لوغانس كمقتل خمسه
اشخاص واصابه سته عشر في قصف الاوكراني
بصواريخ
هذا وقال مسؤولون روس ايضا ان طائره مسيره
اوكرانيه اشعلت حريقا في مصفاه
في جنوب روسيا حيث اكد حاكم منطقه
الروسيه هي السبب المحتمل في اندلاع هذا
الحريق مضيفا ان وحدات الاطفاء اخمدت
الحريق سريعا دون وقت دون وقوع اصابات هذا
وافاد التقارير بان نيران اشتعلت في احدى
وحدات تقطير المازوت في المصفاه جراء سقوط
طائره مسيره
مشاهدينا من
موسكو اذا معنا مراسه العربيه كاتيا طعمه
هو من مدينه
عفوا اذا عبد الجواد اهلا بك واهلا بك
ايضا جواد يعني كيف تبدو الصوره الان في
بيلجورود هل جنحت الاوضاع نحو الهدوء
مرحبا احمد لك وللزميلك كاتيا في الحقيقه
يعني منذ دقائق تم الاعلان ان قريه نوفايا
بتروفكا الواقعه ايضا في جهه الغربيه وهي
من اقليم
شبيبنا تتعرض الان لضربات مسيره وقذائف
مدفعيه قادمه من الجانب الاوكراني حسب
روايه السلطات هناك حتى هذه اللحظه تستمر
المجموعات ويستمر سكان تلك المناطق بنشر
مقاطع الفيديو وما حدث خلال الليله
الماضيه يبدو من المشهد احمد بان ساحه
المدينه تعرضت لضرر كبير سقط فيها قذيفه
صاروخيه حسب الاعلان الرسمي الاصابات حتى
هذه اللحظه بقيت عند اربع اشخاص لكن
الاضرار الماديه طالت شبكه الكهرباء
والاتصال والمياه والكهرباء والطرقات
والعديد من مباني تلك المدينه يعني هو
اقليم مشتعل نوعا ما الجميع ينتظر طبعا
حديث عمده
للحديث عن ما جرى يوم امس من قصف لمركز
اللاجئين المؤقت بحيث طبعا هذا العمده قام
بالغاء البث المباشر الذي يقوم به يوميا
تبعا لموضوع الامس وما حدث من هذا القصف
حتى هذه اللحظه الحصيله النهائيه للخسائر
البشريه والماديه لم تعلن رسميا خلال
الاربع والعشرين ساعه الماضيه لكن طبعا
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي وخاصه في
تيليجرام والقنوات من تحديدا تقوم الان
بنشر مقاطع فيديو واخبار عن الخسائر وما
يحدث من عمليه استهداف في تلك طيب اسمحي
بالانتقال الى به كاتب من جديد ودفاع
الروسيه كما تابعنا وصفت الهجمات
الاوكرانيه على الاراضي الروسيه
بالارهابيه هل يتم الحديث حاليا عن طبيعه
الرد الذي يمكن ان تتبناه موسكو ردا على
هذه الهجمات
مرحبا احمد بالفعل اولا سابدا ان الهجمات
المسيرات باستخدام مسيرات على الاراضي
الروسيه لا تزال مستمره منذ الصباح اليوم
كان هناك
هجوم باستخدام عشر مسيرات على منطقه تم
اسقاطها بانظمه الدفاع الجويه الروسيه
بالاضافه الى مهاجمه منطقه كريستدار ايضا
سقطت المسيره فوق مصفاه النفط ولكن لم
تؤدي الى اشتعال حريق ولكن في نفس المنطقه
تم سقطت مسيره اخرى على محطه محطه الوقود
ادت الى اشتعال النيران وبالتالي ثم
اخمادها وسيطر عليها دون وقوع طبعا خسائر
بشريه اذا هذه الهجمات تستمر
على الاراضي الروسيه يوم امس كنا شاهدنا
هجوم وصل الى العاصمه الروسيه موسكو وهذا
ما وصفه ومواصفاته موسكو انه بالعمل
الارهابي وانه كان كما تحدث الرئيس الروسي
بمثابه الرد من الجانب الاوكراني على
عمليه ناجحه كانت قد نفذتها روسيا على احد
صناع القرار في مراكز صناع القرار في
اوكرانيا وهو يعني طبعا هنا الاستخبارات
مركز استخبارات اوكرانيا تم قصفه من اجانب
الروسي حقيقه حتى الان هناك طبعا سيكون من
تبعيات هذا الهجوم الاوكراني على العاصمه
سيكون لها رد وكما اعتدنا على موسكو انها
دائما تكثف هجماتها في حال كان هناك
استهداف لمناطق او مناطق استراتيجيه
كالعاصمه الروسيه موسكو وقبلها ايضا كان
هناك استهداف للكرملين كما تعمل تعلم احمد
ومن قبله استهداف المناطق سواء كانت
حدوديه عسكريه او كانت استراتيجيه كشبه
جزيره القرن عندما تم استهداف جسر شبه
جزيره العرب ولكن من جانب اخر رسميا كانت
المتحدثه الرسميه باسم الخارجيه مريضه
كانت قد علقت اليوم على هذه الهجمات
وبالتحديد هنا الموقف الغربي اعتبرته بم
انها رده الفعل على هذه الهجمات هي طبعا
لا تتناسب تتناسب مع خطوره الهجمات التي
تقوم بها كيف ضد الاراضي الروسيه احمد عبد
الجواد الاهداف التي اشرت اليها قبل قليل
والتي طالتها الهجمات الاوكرانيه في
بيجورود هي اهداف مدنيه لكن ماذا عن
الاهداف العسكريه او المناطق العسكريه هل
طارتها اي هجمات وماذا عن التواجد العسكري
الروسي ايضا في وما اذا كان هناك رد متوقع
ايضا من انطلاق من بالقروض الى الداخل
الاوكراني
احمد يعني ليله الامس عند الساعه الثانيه
12 يعني عند منتصف الليل بدات القوات
الروسيه بتوجيه ضربات نحو العمق الاوكراني
لم يتم الحديث رسميا عن هذا الموضوع لكن
طبعا معظم سكان هذه المدينه يتحدثون عن
هذا الشيء يعرفون من صوت الضربات بشكل جيد
ان كان تم توجيهها من قبل الداخل في اقليم
بيلجورود او يعني تم استقبالها من الخارج
هذا بما يخص هذا الموضوع طبعا تكثيف
القوات الامنيه هو متواجد نوعا ما حكومه
هذا الاقليم توجهت قبل نحو اسبوع من الان
بتكثيف عدد القوات خاصه بعد محاوله
الاجتياح التي طالت هذا الاقليم من جهته
الغربيه نوعا ما هناك تواجد للمعدات
العسكريه لكن كل هذه المعلومات تبقى حكرا
وتبقى سرا نوعا ما لا يمكن الوصول اليها
طبعا لحساسيه الوضع بشكل كبير احمد اما
بما يخص طبعا الامور المدنيه فهي متاحه
بشكل كبير والاصابات والاضرار يتم احصائها
والاعلان عنها رسميا اذا ساتي بهذا القدر
شكرا لك زميلي من الروسيه مراسله العربي
عبر جواد الرشد وشكر لك ايضا من واصل كنت
معنا ممارسه العربيه كاتيا طعمه تحياتي
كاتيا وعبد جواد
مشاهدينا مع ثمار شن القوات الروسيه هجمات
على العاصمه الاوكرانيه
للذهاب للملاجئ والاختباء في مثل الانفاق
هربا من سقوط الركام على منازلهم نتابع
انها ليست اول ليله بلا نوم فاننا نقضي
الليل في الممر لكن هذا لا يغير حياتنا
فنحن نواصل الحياه ونستمر في الاستمتاع
بها
اذهب الى الملجا في المترو لانه الشيء
الصحيح الذي يجب القيام به يمكن ان يصبح
الامر خطيرا جدا في الخارج ويمكن ان يسقط
الحطام عليك لهذا السبب لا توجد خيارات
اخرى حقا غير الماوى
بعد ذوي صفارات الانذار للغاره الجويه لم
يكن لدينا الوقت الكافي للركض الى الملجا
في المترو لكن توقفنا في احد المقاهي التي
تحتوي على ملجا
العالم يدرك ان المعتدين خسروا هذه الحرب
وبالطريقه التي اراها انها الام موتهم
وانها اخر نوبات الغضب والكراهيه تجاه
الاوكرانيين
اكد المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه رفع القروسي ان وضع الامن والسلام
النوويه في محطه زابوريا الاوكرانيه
للطاقه النوويه لا يزال هشا وخطيرا للغايه
وشدد الكرسي في افاده امام مجلس الامن على
ان شدد على ضروره عدم تعرض المحطه الخطر
واستخدامها كمخزل او قاعده للاسلحه
الثقيله
اليوم يشكل خطوه في الاتجاه الصحيح فيما
يتعلق بسلامه محطه للطاقه النوويه
الدعم لعملنا بما في ذلك للمبادئ الخمسه
التي حددتها مشجع
هذا ما اعلنه المدير العام للوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
امام مجلس الامن الدولي
اول هذه المبادئ عدم شن هجوم من اي نوع من
او على المحطه ولا سيما استهداف المفاعلات
او الوقود او بنى تحتيه او الموظفين
وتشمل المبادئ ايضا عدم استخدام الموقع
لتخزين اسلحه ثقيله او حشد عسكريين
وان لا تفصل المحطه عن شبكه الكهرباء وان
تتم حمايتها من اعمال التخريب
هذه المبادئ الاساسيه الخمسه حظيت بتاييد
واسع النطاق ولم يعارضها اي صوت
على حد قول المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه
جروسي اكد ان الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه تعتزم بدء مراقبه تطبيق هذه
المبادئ من خلال بعثتها في الموقع
نشاطنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
ازمه كوسو وتضغط على الحلفاء الغربيين
واشنطن تعاقب عاصمتها
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد في اول عقوبه
بعد تسليم البان مهامهم رسميا على راس
بلديات في مدن شمال كوسوفو اعلنت الولايات
المتحده استبعاد كوسو من برنامج لتدريبات
عسكريه حيث اعلن السفير الامريكي فينا
استبعاد كوسوفو من برنامج تدريبات
العسكريه المشتركه 23 الذي يضم اكثر من 20
دوله كما هدد السفير الامريكي باتخاذ
اجراءات غير مسبوقه لانهاء الدعم
الدبلوماسي لاعتراف الدولي بكوسوفو التي
مازال استقلالها موضع نزاع بين الصربياء
وبعض الدول الاوروبيه هذا وانتقد وزير
الخارجي الامريكيه رئيس الوزراء الكوسوفي
معتبرا ان قراره بشان بشان رؤساء الباديات
ادى الى تفاقم التوتر بشده والى ضروره
ودعم لينك كل الاطراف الى اتخاذ اجراءات
فوريه لنزع فتيل للتوتر مدينا العنف غير
المقبول ضد قوات حفظ السلام
هذا واظهرت مقاطع مصوره انتشار قوات حفظ
السلام التابعه لحلف شمال الاطلسي في
كوسوفو حيث جاء ذلك بعد اعلان حلف الناتو
ارساله لسبعمائه فرد من قوته الى كوسوفو
كما اصيب العشرات من قوات حفظ السلام عند
اشتباكهم مع الصرب ما اثار مخاوف من تصعيد
اكبر بين صربيا وكوسوفو
اعلن الادعاء العام في الدرعيه الالمانيه
قال سبعه اشخاص يشتبه بانتمائهم لتنظيم
داعش ووجه الادعاء الالماني لهم تهمه جمع
اموالين صالح تنظيم داعش وارسالها الى
التنظيم في سوريا والمشاركه ايضا في
تحويلات ماليه تبلغ خمسه وستين الف يورو
كان هدفها الاساسي المساعده على هروب
اعضاء من التنظيم من مخيم الهول
اولا تنتقودها طهران باتجاه القاهره
لاستعاده العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين
البلدين فقد حث الرئيس الايراني وزاره
الخارجيه لاتخاذ كافه الاجراءات اللازمه
للتعزيز العلاقات مع القاهره
مشاهدينا ايضا معنا الدكتور محمد عباس
ناجي رئيس تحرير مجله مختارات ايرانيه
اهلا بك دكتور محمد معنا في هذه الساعه
الاخباريه وبدايه كيف تتلقف مصر هذه
الاشارات الايرانيه الداعيه لتطبيع
العلاقات معها وفق قراءتك لضد الفعل حتى
اللحظه
اهلا وسهلا بك استاذ احمد انا اعتقد انه
قرار رئيس رئيسي بتكليف وزاره الخارجيه
باجراء الاتصالات الخاصه
بالتطويل العلاقات مع مصر جاء بعد
التصريحات التي ادلى بها المرشد الاعلى
علي خلال لقائه مع سلطان عمان منذ ايام
قليله والتي ادى فيها دعمه لتطويل
العلاقات مع مصر لكن في كل الاحوال
بالنسبه للقاهره انا اعتقد المساله الاهم
في هذا السياق هو ان تتحول هذه التصريحات
او الاقوال الى افعال على الارض او
اجراءات خطوات اجرائيه على الارض توحي
بانه ايران بالفعل في سبيل تغيير موقفها
في بعض الازمات في المنطقه والتعامل
بايجابيه مع المناخ الجديد الذي ظهر في
الشرق الاوسط هناك مصطلحات عديده تطور في
العلاقات بين ايران والسعوديه والعلاقات
بين ايران وبعض الدول الاخرى الى جانب حتى
علاقات تركيا مع مصر ومحاولات مع النظام
السوري وغيرها في الفتره الاخيره عوده
سوريا الى الجماعه العربيه القاهره تنظر
وتحاول تقييم كل هذه التطورات وهو موقف
ايران منها ومدى امكانيه ان تساهم ايران
في تسويه ازمات اقليميه مختلفه وفي
مقدمتها الملف اليمني الى جانب الملف
الفلسطيني وبعد الملفات وهناك العديد من
الملفات التي ينتظر فيها
مراجعه موقفي ايران منها لكن دعنا نتابع
بعض محطات التقارب المصري الايراني من
خلال التقرير التالي ونعود اليك من جنس
محمد
عقود
من القنوات الدبلوماسيه بين مصر وايران
تنتهي باشارات على عوده المياه الى
مجاريها لكن الخطوات نحو التقارب تبدو
اكثر وضوحا من اتجاه واحد وهو اتجاه طهران
القاهره توجيهات اصدرها الرئيس الايراني
ابراهيم رئيسي للخارجيه الايرانيه لاتخاذ
كافه الاجراءات اللازمه بهدف تعزيز
العلاقات مع مصر
حول تطوير العلاقات مع مصر فانه هو مباشره
بعد تصريحات المرشد الاعلى امر الرئيس
وزاره الخارجيه باتخاذ التدابير اللازمه
لتوطيد وتطوير العلاقات ان شاء الله
جهود ليست بالجديده فعلى مدى اشهر سعت
وصرح الطهران باتجاه تطبيع العلاقات مع
القاهره من ضمنها مقترح من رئيس الوزراء
العراقي محمد شياع السوداني لاطلاق الحوار
بين الطرفين على المستويين الامني
والسياسي وسيط اخر يلعب دورا ظاهرا في
التقارب فتصريحات خامنا المرحبه باستعاده
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه جاءت من خلال زياره
سلطان عمان هيثم بن طارق لطهرعون وفق
التلفزيون الرسمي الايراني وهذه ليست
للمره الاولى التي تتوسط فيها مسقط بين
طهران والاطراف الدوليه
مصر وحتى الان لم تبدي اي تجاوب رسمي حول
الخطوات الايرانيه فقد كان وزير الخارجيه
المصري سامح شكري نفى وجود اي مسار مصري
ايراني لاستعاده العلاقات الا ان مصادر
مصريه صرحت لشرق الاوسط ان القاهره منفتحه
على الاشارات الصريحه التي ترسلها طهران
الى عمر العربيه
نعود مره اخرى الى الضفه دكتور محمد عباس
ناجي رئيس تحرير مجله مختارات ايرانيه
للوساطه بين ايران وبين القاهره هناك مسار
عماني وهناك ايضا مسار تتبعه او تنتهجه
العراق هل هما مسراني في رايك
ام انه منفصلا تماما وعلى القاهره ان
تختار ربما احد هاتين المسارين
اعتقد ان الهدف واحد في المصريين وهو ان
تجري او ترفع مستوى الاتصالات بين القاهره
وطهران هناك مكتب رعايه مصالح في القاهره
ومكتب اخر في طهران ربما العاصمتين بغداد
ومسقط تحاولان الان استثمار المناخ
الايجابي الجديد في منطقه شرق الاوسط
لرفع مستوى الاتصالات وربما تطويل
العلاقات بين مصر وايران خلال المرحله
القديمه او لاحظنا بغداد ومسقط كان لهم
دور بارز في
توقيع السعوديه وايران على اتفاق بكين وتم
شكرهم على ذلك من جانب الدولتين والى جانب
الصين عندما تم توقيع الاتفاق في 10 مارس
الماضي وبالتالي هذه ليست المره الاولى
التي تبذل فيها الدولتين جهودا في هذا
السياق دعني اقول انه سلطنه عمان تحديدا
تقوم بدور الوسيط ليس فقط على صعيد تحسين
العلاقات بين ايران
والدول العربيه وانما حتى فيما يتعلق
بالعلاقات بين ايران والدول الغربيه اخرها
ربما التوسط في صفقه تبادل سجناء بين
ايران
وبلجيكا وقبلها بين ايران وبريطانيا
والولايات المتحده وحتى التوسط في الاتفاق
انه لكن في كل الاحوال كما قلت في البدايه
المساله بالنسبه للقاهره هي مساله مراجعه
لماذا امكانيه حدوث تغيير في مواقف ايران
تجاه ملفات تحظى باهتمام خاص من جانب مصر
ماتت على ملف الفلسطيني الملف اليمني موقف
ايران من الميليشيات المسلحه في المنطقه
مساله مكافحه الارهاب وغيرها الى جانب
طبعا امن الخليج وهي قضيه في الامن القومي
المصري كل ذلك انا اعتقد انه سيكون محطه
اهتمام ومراجعه بصوره عامه محمد يعني
المنطقه العربيه تشهد تغيرات جوهريه في
العلاقات بين دول الاقليم تتحدث عن
العلاقات السعوديه الايرانيه الايرانيه
المصريه وكذلك التقارب المصري التركي
لماذا جرحت كل هذه الدول في هذا التوقيت
نحو
تقويه العلاقات بينها هذا توقيت تحدي دا
لماذا
الاكثر من سبب او سبب ما يتعلق بالتطورات
على مستوى الدولي هناك حرب في بين روسيا
واوكرانيا طردت تاثيرات وارتدادات مباشره
على منطقه الشرق الاوسط انها تصور الدول
المنطقه تسعى الان الى تبني اتجاه جديد
نحو اقلمت حل الازمات في المنطقه الشرق
الاوسط وعدم التعويل بشكل كبير على قوه
دوليه كبيره
ربما بدات او تسعى في المقام الاول الى
حمايه مصالحها او دعم مصالحها في المقام
الاول هناك تفكير جديد في انه من الضروري
تبني نمط جديد في التعامل او اداره
العلاقات مع دول المنطقه خصوصا في ايران
ظهر توجه جديد في الفتره الاخيره لا يعفي
ايران من مسؤوليه توتر علاقاتها مع الدول
العربيه ويضغط على ايران من اجل تغيير
موقفها في بعض الملفات التي يمكن ان تحسن
علاقات ايران مع الدول العربيه خلال
المرحله القادمه شكرا لك من القاهره كنت
معنا الدكتور محمد عباس ناجي رئيس
محمد
اثار
حفيظه بعض القوى السياسيه الشيعيه في
العراق بينما اعتبر الجهات اردنيه ان
الحزبه ليس له اي ارتباطات خارجيه ويعمل
تحت مظله القانون الاردني نتابع جدل قديم
جديد فيما يتعلق بحزب البعث العربي
الاشتراكي الاردني بدا منذ عام 2003 جدل
يعود اليوم الى الواجهه بعد تصويب اوضاعه
وفق قانون الاحزاب الاردني الجديد الذي
سمح لسته وعشرين حزبا بالعمل على الساحه
الاردنيه هناك سوء فهم واضح فيما يتعلق في
المرحله الجديده للحياه الحزبيه في الاردن
حزب البعث العربي الاشتراكي الاردني هو
وفق اوضاعه بموجب احكام القانون ولم يرخص
من جديد المطلوب من هذا الحزب فقط العمل
داخل حدود المملكه الاردنيه الهاشميه
بموجب احكام الدستور والقانون النافذ حزب
البعث رد على الانتقادات التي تشنها جهات
في العراق على الاردن بعد السماح له
بالعمل رغم انه محظور هناك بحسب الدستور
ووصفها بالحمله المبرره حزب البعث العربي
الاشتراكي حزب وطني اردني مؤسس منذ 92
ولازال قائم وفق اوضاعه فقط وبالتالي ماء
الزوبعه لثار الان ليست مبرره على الاطلاق
وكلام مش صحيح الاطلاق مش صحيح احنا
موجودين وهي مساله استمرار فقط انا لبيت
شروط القانون هذا اللي سويتهم وما بين جدل
في العراق وقانون اردني تتحدث الاوساط
السياسيه هنا ان حزب البعث الاردني حزب
محلي يمارس نشاطاته داخليا تحت مظله
القانون دون اي تجاوزات او تدخلات خارجيه
مرحله حزبيه جديده في الاردن لم تغادرها
احزاب ديمقراطيه او قوميه ولا يعني ترخيص
حزب البعث الاردني انه منطلق لاستفزاز
الجوار او استدعاء للتاريخ بحسب مراقبينا
هنا وانما هي شروط الحياه الحزبيه
بالالوان والاطياف كافه
تحولت هذه القضيه هنا في بغداد الى ماده
اعلاميه وفرصه لشد عصب جمهور بعض الاحزاب
الشيعيه والتي نظمت وقفات احتجاجيه واصدرت
بيانات الادانه لقرار عمان بتجديد رخصه
عمل حزب البعث العربي الاردني
هناك قوى شيعيه ذهبت الى مطالبه حكومه
السودان باتخاذ مواقف اكثر حده تجاه
الحكومه الاردنيه على خلفيه سماحها لبعض
رموز وقيادات حزب البعث العراقي المنحل
بالاقامه على اراضيها وعلى الحكومه
العراقيه لا تكتفي فقط باستدعاء السفير
الاردني يجب ان يكون هناك موقف تجاه هذه
السياسه انا اعتقد ممارسه نشاط حزب البعث
من داخل
المملكه الاردنيه الهاشميه يشكل خطر ليس
فقط على العراق وانما يشكل خطر على
المنطقه
الشارع العراقي لم يعر اهتماما لما يجري
فقد بات حزب البعث بالنسبه له جزءا من
الماضي والله هذا الشيء داخل الاردن
والعراق ما اله علاقه باي شيء حزب البعث
في الاردني حزب سياسي اردني ياخذ الاجازه
بالاردني يمارس نشاطة سياسي داخل الاردن
وهذا شيء داخلي اردني
غالبيه القوى والفعاليات السياسيه في
العراق اعتبرت مجرى في الاردن شان داخليا
لا يؤثر على العلاقه بين بغداد وعمان
والتي تشهد تطورا كبيرا سياسيا وامنيا
واقتصاديا
الموقف المائي هو ابرز التحديات التي
تواجهها الحكومه العراقيه خلال موسم الصيف
ولاجل ذلك تقوم وزاره الموارد المائيه
بعده اجراءات لرفع التجاوزات عن مياه
الغراف والفرات في مسعى لقيام بخطه زراعيه
وتوفير المياه الصالحه للشرب نتابع
التفاصيل ارض هؤلاء المزارعين مهدده
بالجفاف بفعل التجاوزات للحصص المائيه على
طولي نهر الغراف والفرات في الناصريه جنوب
العراق
وكلما توجهنا شرقا باتجاه الاهوار تزداد
المحنه ويصعب وصول الماء لهذه الاراضي ما
استدعى تقنين المياه من قبل الحكومه
العراقيه لتلافي الجفافه وتوفير المياه
الصالحه للشرب
المياه لمياه ماكو يعني عندك شتوى كامله
احنا ما وقعنا تموت بها على الله نحن من
القديم الزمان يعني الدوله هسه قعد دور
وانا تطور والحديث وهذا يزيد معاناتنا اما
المرشات وما قالت هاي الحديثه هي هي
نحسبها مؤامره ما امره على الفلاح بالنسبه
للقرار السنه حسب راس الوزراء وسمعناه
يعني مو بحقنا يقول لك الطريق الحديثه
ليزرى ماكو زرع الى
اي مواد الماء عده طريقه حديثه يعني
المرشات
المرشات احنا مو ناجحه عندنا ارضنا طينيه
مراجعه ملف المياه داخليا ستشهد اجراءات
تتخذها الحكومه والتي تتمثل بمعاقبه
المخالفين وازاله البحيرات غير المجازه
وغلق منافذ مياه الصرف الصحي غير المعالجه
المسببه لاضرار بيئيه والزام الفلاحين
باستخدام نظام ري حديثه وفق توقيتات زمنيه
مقرره لجميع الوحدات الزراعيه عفوا
والتحدي الاكبر الذي يواجه العراق عموما
ومحافظ ذي قاء خصوصا هو تاثيرات التغير
المناخي والجفاف وهذا اللي اثر الى حدوث
حمائيه كبيره عن نبيها بالموسم الزراعي
السابق وكانت هناك بعض الحلول الانيه في
وقتها هو
القضاء على التجاوز على الحصص المائيه
بعد الاجراءات الداخليه تحشد الحكومه جهود
لاعاده تقييم الموقف المائي مع دول جوار
العراق لمواجهه موسم الصيف بخطه زراعيه
تضمن حصص مياه عادله لجميع المزارعين
وتتدارك توقف عمليات استصلاح الاراضي
الاعوام السابقه من الناصريه شاكر عواد
العربيه
مراره لجنه القواعد في مجلس النواب
الامريكي مشروع قانون سقف الدين وصوت سبعه
اعضاء في اللجنه لصالح المشروع وسته اعضاء
ضده وستكون الخطوه الثانيه التصويت على
المشروع في مجلس النواب وسط اعتراضات من
التقدميين والمحافظين ليرسل بعد ذلك الى
اذا تم تمريره طبعا الى مجلس الشيوخ ويحشد
قاده الكونغرس المشرعين لتمويل المشروع
قبل الخامس من يونيو لتجنب التخلف
الولايات المتحده عن سداد ديونها
مشروع قانون سقف الدين يعبر اختباره الاول
بتمريره من لجنه القواعد في مجلس النواب
كخطوه اولى للتصويت عليه في المجلس قبل
ارساله الى مجلس الشيوخ
عدد من النواب الجمهوريين تعهدوا قبل
التصويت في اللجنه بفعل ما بوسعهم لايقافه
فيما هدد النائب شيبراير رئيس المجلس كابل
مقارتي بازاحته من منصبه اذا تم تمريره
الاتفاق هذه المجموعه ستعارضه سنواصل
محاربته اليوم وغدا وبغض النظر عما يحدث
سيكون هناك حساب حول ما حدث ما لم نوقف
هذا القانون بحلول يوم غد بدوره دافع
مقرتي عن الاتفاق لست متاكدا مما يريده
الجميع لم نحصل على كل ما اردناه ولم يكن
بالامكان التحدث عن الميزانيه باكملها
خلال المحادثات وفي سعي لحج التاييد
لمشروع القانون اعتبرت مديره الميزانيه في
البيت الابيض واحدى كبار المفوضين بشان
الصفقه شايلنديا ان الاتفاق مكسب للشعب
الامريكي
عندما نتحدث عن التخلف عن السادات فقد
انتصر الشعب الامريكي اليوم خاصه عندما
يصل المشروع الى مكتب الرئيس لاننا تجنبنا
ما كان يمكن ان يكون كارثيا تماما مسار
الاتفاق ليس سهلا في ظل غضب مشرعين من
اليمين الجمهوري وقلقي مشرعين من اليسار
الديمقراطي بسبب ما يرونه تنازلات قدمها
كل من الرئيس جو بايدن ورئيس المجلس كبل
المقارفي
بالتزامن مع ذلك يحجد قاده الحزبين في
الكونجرس الدعم للتشريع للتصويت عليه في
مجلس النواب اولا ثم مجلس الشيوخ حيث
يواجه ايضا معارضه جمهوريه
اعلن انه لن يصوت لصالح الاتفاق واقترح
بدلا من ذلك رفع سقف الدين ب500 مليار
دولار فقط والعوده الى طاوله المفاوضات في
غضون اشهر قليله لوضع اصلاحات اضافيه
للانفاق
وكان السيناتور الجمهوري مايكلي هدد سابقا
بعرقله الصفقه لعدم تضمنها اصلاحات كبيره
في الانفاق والميزانيه حسب تعبيره حسين
الطوض العربيه واشنطن
مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل
بعد عشره ايام في الفضاء هبوط ناجح لمركبه
دراغون التي تقل رائدي الفضاء السعوديين
ريانه وعلي
اطلاق نار وتحليق للطيران الحربي في
الخرطوم والجيش يعلق مشاركته في مفاوضات
جده
يعتبر المسؤولين العسكريين البريطانيين
اهدافا مشروعه لدعم بلادهم لاوكرانيا
الادعاء الالماني يتهم سبعه اشخاص بجمع
اموال لصالح داعش وارسالها للتنظيم في
سوريا
محاولات تقودها طهران باتجاه القاهره
لاستعاده العلاقات بين البلدين وصمت مصري
رسمي
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد اعلنت الهيئه
السعوديه للفضاء نجاح مهمه رائدى الفضاء
السعوديين ريان برناوي وعلي القرني بهبوط
المركبه الفضائيه التي تقلهما وطاقم
المهمه بعد رحله علميه متميزه في محطه
الفضاء الدوليه هذا وتابعت العربيه مراحل
عوده مهمه الفضاء التي تحمل رايدين الفضاء
السعوديين على متن المركبه الفضائيه
دراغون الى الارض بعد رحله لعشره ايام في
الفضاء وهبطت المركبه بسلام قباله سواحل
ولايه فلوريدا الامريكيه بعد 12 ساعه
استغرقتها رحله العوده
[موسيقى]
هذا وهنا الرئيس التنفيذي لهيئه الفضاء
السعودي الدكتور محمد التميمي القياده
السعوديه والشعب على اكتمال المهمه
العلميه للمملكه في محطه في محطه الفضاء
الدوليه عقب نجاحه هبوط مركبه رئيس الفضاء
ريان برناوي
ووصولهما بسلام الى الارض من مركز
العمليات الموحد لمتابعه رواد الفضاء
بالرياض وبعد وصول رواد الفضاء قبل قليل
للارض سالمين ولله الحمد وهنئ القياده
وهنئ مولاي خادم الحرمين الشريفين واسمه
سيدي ولي العهد والشعب السعودي بسلامه
رواد الفضاء وبارك لهم نجاح هذه الرحله
العلميه التاريخيه والتي ستسهم في رفعه
الوطن ومكانته في خدمه العلم والابتكار
وخدمه البشريه
اذا مشاهدينا عقب اطلاق كوريا الشماليه
صاروخان باليستيا اعلنت اليابان انما تقوم
انتهاك لقرارات مجلس الامن الدولي حيث
قارن المتحدث باسم الحكومه اليابانيه
على كوريا الشماليه وادانتها بشده هذا
وكان المشاهدين اطلقت ما زعمت بانه صاروخ
فضائي واعترفت بعد ذلك في فشل الاطلاق كما
تعهد بالمحاوله مره اخرى في اسرع وقت ممكن
بحسب وكاله يونيون هاب للانب الكوريه
الجنوبيه
[موسيقى]
هذا ودانا قائد القوات الامريكيه في
المحيطين الهادئ والهندي اطلاق كوريا
الشماليه قمر صناعيا باعتبار ذلك انتهاكا
صريحا لقراره الامم المتحده حيث اكدت
القياده بان اطلاق الاقمار الصناعيه
التابعه لكوريا الشماليه يتضمن تقنيات
تعلق ببرنامج الصواريخ الباريسيه لكن بحسب
وكاله الانباء الكوريه الشماليه فان الغرض
منها هو مواجهه التحركات العسكريه الخطيره
للولايات المتحده واتباعها
نفت وزاره السياحه والاثار المصريه نفت
وجود اي عمليه في ازاله لاي مقابر اثريه
ووصفتها بالشائعات نتابع نحن الان في
منطقه المقابر المحيطه بميدان مسجد السيده
نفيسه هذه المنطقه كانت حديث المصريين عبر
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي بسبب قرارات
ازاله والهدف هو انشاء محاور مروريه جديده
تستمر عمليات الهدم والازاله للعديد من
المقابر في مناطق الامام الشافعي والسيده
عائشه والسيده نفيسه ما اثار لغطا دفع
وزاره السياحه والاثار لاصدار بيان ينفي
ازاله اي مقابر اثريه ويصف الجدل الدائره
بالشائعات متخصصون وضحوا ان المقابر
المسجله كاثار لا يمكن هدمها او ازالتها
وفقا للقانون اتحدى ان واحد يثبت لي ان
هناك اثر ازيل
فيش
للدوله
لجات للاثار
ادونا مخطط الاثار اللي موجود عندكم طب ما
احنا على مدار التاريخ المصري
ازيلت جبانات لا حصر لها زي جبانه الرويعي
اللي اتعمل مكانها ميدان العتبه والمباني
اللي موجوده فيه والمسرح القومي والحاجات
دي كلها ولكن الانتقادات ركزت على ان
قرارات الازاله تشمل مقابر لعدد من
الشخصيات التاريخيه المصريه والعربيه
بالاضافه الى ان بعض المقابر تحمل طرازا
معماريا تاريخيا يعكس تراثا لتلك الحقب
منطقه ديت هي منطقه كان بدا فيها الدفن من
وقت دخول سيدنا عمر بن العاص لما اخذ جبل
مقطم ودفن بعد كذا يعني الموت حوله
وبالتالي المنطقه ديت لو احنا يعني بدانا
عملنا فيها فرقه سريع حاجه اسمها فرق
انقاذ حنقدر نطلع منها اثار لا حصر لها
بعض الورثه من اصحاب المقابر تقدموا بطعون
ضد قرارات الازاله الازمه وصلت الى
البرلمان مش عشان طريق ولا محور ولا ولا
كوبري جديد اهد او اعمل ازاله لكوبري او
لضريح يكون له طابع مميز جدا ومفترض ان
انا استغله
بصوره سياحيه جميله وحافظ عليه وبالعكس
اطوره واخليه فعلا يبقى متحف مفتوح سواء
للمصريين او للاجانب ويستمروا الانقسام
بين فريق يفضل استمرار عمليات التوسعات
المروريه للمدينه المزدحمه وفريق اخر
يطالب بالحفاظ على ملامح مصر التاريخيه
احمد عثمان العربيه القاهره
في ظل استمرار اليهودي الولايات المتحده
لحضره تيك توك التطبيقات الصينيه تحظى
بشعبيه كبيره رخصه الامريكيين نتابع
[موسيقى]
رياح شعبيه تيك توك والتطبيقات الصينيه
الاخرى تجري بما لا تشتهي سفينه واشنطن
جهود الاحتواء عادت بنتائج عكسيه تطبيقات
صينيه انتشرت بين المستخدمين الامريكيين
بشكل كبير في الفتره الاخيره منصه
ابتكرتها الشركه المالكه لتيك توك بايك
دانس الامر يتعلق بتطبيق ليمن ات الذي
يجمع ميزات تطبيقات اخرى وهو موجه لفئه
الشباب والمراهقين تطبيق يستخدمه حوالي
مليون و 800 الف شخص شهريا فضلا عن تطبيق
كاب كات المخصص لتوضيب المقاطع المصوره
والذي يستخدمه 99 مليون شخص اضافه الى
منصه التجاره الالكترونيه شيء ب 855 مليون
عمليه تنزيل في الولايات المتحده منذ
بدايته على الرغم من ان التقديرات تشير
الى حوالي 22 مليون مستخدم نشط شهريا
وتيميو الذي حقق المرتبه
مليون مستخدم تشترك هذه التطبيقات في بعض
الميزات التي اثارت قلق الحكومه الامريكيه
مع تيك توك حول ما اذا كانت هذه الشركات
تحمي بيانات المستخدم الامريكي غير ان
الخبراء يقولون ان هناك اختلافات مهمه بين
هذه التطبيقات وتيك توك ما قد يفسر النقص
النسبي في الاهتمام بها من بين اهم هذه
الامور حجم وجود هذه التطبيقات في
الولايات المتحده الى غايه الان الذي لا
يضاهي حجما انتشار تيك توك تطبيقات تحقق
انتشارا متناميا بين صفوف الامريكيين في
وقت تسعى الولايات المتحده لمواجهه منصه
تيك توك بسبب ما تعتبره تهديدا لامنها
القومي غير ان خبراء امريكيين يدعمون فكره
خلق بدائل منافسه للتطبيقات الصينيه قصد
مواجهتها والحد من انتشارها بلال البجتين
العربيه
للعناوين مشاهدينا
ذوي اطلاق نار وتحريق للطيران الحربي في
الخرطوم والجيش يغلق يعلق مشاركته في
مفاوضات جده
يعتبر المسؤولين العسكريين البريطانيين
اهدافا مشروعه لدعم بلادهم لاوكرانيا
محاوله تقودها طهران باتجاه القاهره
لاستعاده العلاقات بين البلدين وصمت مصري
رسمي
نهايه هذه الساعه الاخباريه مشاهدينا حسن
المتابعه وفي امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات